good hey there I'm Aria and we're here
in the San Fernando Valley the heart
some might say of the adult
entertainment industry to take a look
behind the scenes at where the sausage
is made here at the Vixen offices please
lead the way I don't know I heard you
guys were troublemakers
Abigail starts our day with a quick tour
so welcome to the Vixen office this is
an award-winning studio yeah milk
mystery guy Greg Lansky Best
Cinematography best specialty movie
other genre come inside me best ethnic
interracial series best solo tease
performance for you I got two of them up
there is there a movie you've done that
you're very proud of but the awards they
just snubbed it I was a girl performer
for three years and I never won a girl
girl performance scene which I thought
was a little ridiculous because I was
very I feel like good at what I did but
you give me you've won - yes you're kind
of like the Meryl Streep of the porn
industry wait this looks familiar
oh it's you you work for this being able
to see Abigail's film with her was was a
bit of an experience this is all by your
savings - what are you saying - a minute
right I'm probably saying like I'm
and I'm stuff like that yeah I will say
this though I mean you guys didn't see
it it looked incredible cinematography
was top-notch it's like I was watching a
Terrence Malick film although actually I
was going on
shortly after Greg Lansky the man many
consider to be revolutionising the porn
industry arrives well today you know
we're going to announce our newest vixen
angel it's a pretty big event for us we
do it every month I created really this
title in this crowning in order to
celebrate the women of the adult
industry in the light that is not often
the case so today is all about her
previous angels including abigail are
now live on Instagram to help make the
announcement in the pink over there
that's Nicole she's uh she's about to be
announced as the newest vixen angel this
Instagram story is live right now the
only people to ever watch my Instagram
stories are my parents
[Applause]
[Applause]
and we are done boom now we move for
here in the south-central is this
south-central alright we are now here in
south-central where we are shooting the
coals a usual photo shoot it's crazy
it's a very foggy in here to barely see
but it's looking very very cool and it
should be a very exciting afternoon if
you covered just try to do what I can to
help
[Music]
high pressure guys
lots of shots to cover so I'm saying no
no no that was nice this one right there
oh my god amazing
you look incredible as you walking
ah so close it's gone really well while
today honestly it's really worth it I
mean it's it's a lot of fun and
something different I've never done
before and I love the projects that you
come up with the concepts the ideas they
all really comes together really
beautifully to learn more about what's
setting vixen apart in the industry i
chat with angel of the year kendra
Sunderland
I remember when Greg wanted to make me
the very first vixen angel and I just
like I cried I was like I'm just so
happy because my whole life I've never
been a winner
I've got last place medals for every
sport possible and so for him to like
pick me to be the very first and lead it
and everything I was just so honored it
was really overwhelming
one thing that Greg really wanted to do
is to just show that this is really just
artistic and our pictures are art and we
deserve to be respected as artists
because we're more than that Lauren
doesn't just have to be is like cheap
camera like a hotel stuff you know
people tell us all the time you don't
even have a real job shooting with Greg
it's it's more than just a job it's like
being a part of a project and something
way bigger than that so I'm really glad
that he advocates for us that what we do
is art because we get enough crap from
people it's great to have him you know
to remind us that we are artists and
what we do Oh Greg write what a day what
a day long day it is 7 o'clock wrap on
time wrap on thumb always how do you
feel it went honestly don't know where
I'm great Nicole was amazing she looked
really powerful and every one of the
Vixen angel we really want to celebrate
the woman of the adult industry and show
a powerful image so you know it's boxing
it's coming out of a helicopter it's all
kinds of fun theme we want to stop the
preconceived notion that anything adult
has cheap it can be creative it can be
artistic we define what we do we
want to stop having the adult industry
being cast in the shadow have people
learn to you know question at least the
preconceived notions they have of the
adult industry because when people look
at this they see that wow these people
put in a lot of effort a lot of money a
lot of means just to get fantastic shots
because that's what we're about we like
to do things grant grant is definitely
word I would use to sell this stuff
obviously my final question for you is
if I wanted to get on your ear chest of
male talent right okay well you know
just just write me an email photo front
and back but what a heat of action you
always need a back shot you always need
a backside
[Music]
I'm very happy right now
[Music]